agent is bound on your position  following the retreat of the last man  battalion other factions are taking over  the city in Columbus Circle writers have  seized one of the Indian websites  abandoned by the lmd now they control  the entire Manhattan airspace and are  taking possession of our subtitles take  back the area  this is your second incursion clear sky  find the best strategy to defeat an  overwhelming force of Riker's and be  rewarded with some of the finest loot  conflict introduces more high-end  weapons and top-of-the-line gear sets  unlock them and try out new powerful  effects to match your gameplay stone  new enemy leaders are appearing all over  Manhattan discover their whereabouts and  keep them down  darkstone extractions just became even  more intense interrupt ongoing  extractions by cutting the road to have  all the loot drop to the ground  protect your loot at all costs  get three major expansions and exclusive  bonuses with the season pass  you